ميدانيا قالت كتائب القسام ان مقاتليها
استهدفوا قوه اسرائيليه متحصنه في منزل
غرب مدينه خانيونس جنوب قطاع غزه بقذيفه
مضاده للافراد وايقاع افراد القوه بين
قتيل وجريح وفي ذات المنطقه اعلنت كتائب
القسام ان مقاتليها استهدفوا دبابتين
اسرائيليتين من نوع ميركافا بقذيفه
الياسين 105 وفي الشيخ عجلين جنوب غرب
مدينه غزه اشتبك مقاتل القسام قوه
اسرائيليه راجله مكونه من ثمانيه جنود
واوقع عناصرها بين قتيل وجريح في غرب مخيم
المغازي اعلنت القسام استدراج قوه
اسرائيليه قوامها سبعه جنود الى كمين
وتفجير نفق فيهم كما اعلنت القسام استهداف
دبابتين ميركافا بعبوه شواظ وقذيفة
دبابه ميركافا وجراف من طراز دي ت بقذائف
الياسين 105 وقذائف تان
دوم